[Musique]
donc les commissions scolaires vont être
transformés en centres de service
les élections scolaires et les postes de
commissaires vont être abonné ça va être
les équipes écoles qui vont prendre des
décisions qui les concernent
extrait du discours inaugural du premier
ministre françois legault la semaine
dernière qu'il a réitéré haut et fort
l'éducation c'est sa grande priorité
mais il veut transformer à les
commissions scolaires en centre de
services aux écoles également abolir les
élections scolaires ça fait pas les
affaires de la fédération des
commissions scolaires du québec et non
plus des commissions scolaires
anglophones avec moi rosso kaufmann qui
est directeur général de l'association
des commissions scolaires anglophones du
québec bonjour bonjour
alors tout d'abord votre réaction à
cette promesse de françois legault qui a
été réitérée dans son discours inaugural
donc il veut le faire rapidement
nous sommes pas surpris ça a été dit
pendant la campagne ça a été inclus dans
le plateforme de la coalition à venir au
québec
est-ce que ça va se faire rapidement
c'est une autre question
mais il faut appeler un chat un chat ce
n'est pas une transformation des
commissions scolaires ce sont ces
l'abolition des commissions scolaires
l'abolition des élections scolaires et
le boss les postes de commissaires
scolaires alors de prétendre que ça va
être une petite transformation dans un
réseau qui compte au delà de 3000 écoles
et centres je pensais est inexact et
pourquoi vous vous opposez à cette
transformation ou à cette abolition les
comme si on scolaire comme vous le dites
mais de nous croyons que les commissions
scolaires sont un lien important entre
la communauté et les écoles deuxièmement
les commissions scolaires sont un palier
d'administration ou de gouvernance
locale démocratique qui n'est pas très
dispendieux les coûts sont à peu près 5%
ou en mode 2 5% pour administrer un
réseau d'écoles dans le code des
commissions scolaires anglophones de 340
écoles et centres et de troisièmement le
communauté anglophone a un droit de
contrôler et gérer c'est un titre ces
institutions scolaires éducatifs
alors particulier pour les communautés
anglophones c'est qu'elles sont beaucoup
plus attachés à leur commission scolaire
que les commissions scolaires
francophones par exemple pour les
élections scolaires le taux de
participation est bien plus supérieur
donc vous êtes plus attachés à
l'institution les commissions scolaires
et vous voulez vous battre vous voulez
aller jusque devant les tribunaux pour
empêcher ce tir s'il faut effectivement
le taux de participation dans la
dernière élection scolaire était autour
de 18% ce qui était suffisant on l'admet
mais il faut pas jeter le bébé avec
l'eau du bain
on peut faire des choses pour augmenter
le niveau de participation
mais si vous desservez sa proximité avec
les écoles se serait pas une bonne ça
dépend qui gère le centre de services
marne à croix nous avons l'impression de
n'être que c'est le gouvernement du
québec qui va avoir la mainmise sur les
centres de service que le la
participation de la communauté sera
presque zéro le gouvernement parle des
paras mais la communauté anglophone et
les anglophones tout court ont intérêt à
participer dans cette dans l'éducation
de nos enfants
ou est ce que c'est la disparition des
commissaires scolaires qui vous tiennent
plus à coeur est ce que c'est ça qui
vous dérange le plus c'est une alliée de
démocratie locale qui est très important
et pourquoi je vous donne mon exemple je
n'ai plus d'enfants dans le système de
réseau public anglophone
est ce que j'aurai pas le droit de
participer dans le choix d'un
commissaire scolaire à l'avenir parce
qu'on veut abolir les commissions
scolaires et les postes les élections
scolaires
nous ne croyons poste une bonne chose ni
pour le québec ni pour la communauté
anglophone et nous jouissons des droits
constitutionnels
en vertu de la charte canadienne des
droits et libertés l'article 23 de
contrôler et gérer nos institutions
d'éducation hôtel de la minorité
linguistique effectivement qui protège
les franco canadiens et qui protège les
anglo-québécois vous voyez un lien avec
ce qui se passe en ontario actuellement
avec la lutte que mènent les
franco-ontariens absolument il ya un
lien direct quand on attaque le droit
des minorités linguistiques ailleurs
certains attaquent sur tous les toits
juridictions qui ont aboli les
commissions scolaires et ça ma nouvelle
écosse les du prince édouard et le yukon
dans ces trois cola les gouvernements
ont
maintenu les commissions scolaires
francophones de la minorité intacte pour
afin d'être en conformité avec la charte
alors nous croyons que la jurisprudence
est clair qu'il ya des précédents ce
législatif nouvelle écosse et du prince
édouard et le yukon pourquoi te toucher
tout ça pourquoi chambarder le réseau à
un moment où il faut concentrer sur le
succès des élèves sur les services aux
nouveaux ministres éducation gens
fassent un robert je lui dis que ça va
passer le test des tribunaux a même si
vous allez devant avec les arguments que
vous présentez est-ce que vous avez
réclamé une
je sais que vous l'avez réclamer la
rencontre avec lui est ce que vous avez
une réponse c'est finalement finalement
jeudi après midi on a une confirmation
d'une rencontre avec le ministre on a
bien hâte on veut collaborer avec le
gouvernement du québec avec le ministre
mais nous allons nous défendre et nous
allons utiliser tous les outils
nécessaires pour défendre nos
commissions scolaires je comprends le
ministre dit quelqu'un a dit le mot
commission scolaire n'est pas dans
l'inconscient canadienne mais il ya la
jurisprudence en vertu de l'article 23
qui va jusqu'à la cour suprême du canada
alors il faut pas simplement lire
l'inconscient ou la charte canadienne
des droits et libertés faut prendre dans
notre son contexte de jurisprudence
vous êtes déterminés à vous rendre
jusqu'en cour suprême s'il le faut
s'il le faut il la rencontre avec les
ministres robert ça va se faire quand
c'est prévu que c'est bientôt on va
tenter avec nos collègues de la
fédération des commissions scolaires du
québec de le convaincre de ne pas aller
de l'avant avec son projet tout court
pour le québec on pense pas c'est une
bonne chose mais nous allons ajouter cet
argument additionnel pour la communauté
anglophone qui est noël au droit
constitionnel à suivre donc mais c'est
quand même merci d'avoir été là ce matin
a plaidé en vain